Yeah.
Dust off your time,
machines and sediment thousand years into the past when you get there,
grabbed the nearest English speaker.
How can you tell they're the ones that sound like this?
Our phone or their therapist?
We'll do it our cabinet.
No hop back in and turn that dial 1000 years into the future.
What will future English be like?
Huh?
Since most of us don't have time machines,
how can we predict the future at all with fortune tellers and crystal balls or
maybe with physics,
which predicts that if a certain object travels a certain speed for a set amount
of time,
it will cover a certain distance.
No more,
no less.
Say your mom jumps in Zoomcar and tears away at 92 miles per hour for 15
minutes.
When we pull out a really,
really long ruler to measure how far she's gone,
this equation predicts that she'll travel precisely 23 miles.
Great,
but where's the foolproof equation for predicting complex social things like
languages?
This isn't physics.
You say,
well,
are there at least trends?
Okay,
here's a possibility.
Complicated words with a lot of moving pieces often gets simpler over time.
It's not a rule,
but maybe we could find more of these patterns,
but it gets more complicated because our languages looking feel will depend on
the path it takes through future history.
I mean,
sometimes the single language branches out into a full family tree.
The progeny might differ suddenly from one town to the next or they might sound
totally different from each other.
We'll future English actually turn into an entire family,
but that family doesn't have to come from proper English.
Close your eyes and picture what English looks like to you.
Did you see this if your name's professor come through?
You sure did.
The people living in this inner circle think they speak the real English,
but future English could be an underdog champ from India or China or even inner
city slang,
dog,
remote islands,
jungles,
mountain villages.
These kinds of places are sometimes home to rare languages that are almost like
living fossils.
Well,
future English survive like a time capsule giving future scholars the chance
tomorrow hold.
Wow.
This remnant sounds almost as quaint and archaic is people did back in the year
2014 languages can take the middle road changing and not changing at the same
time.
It sounds weird at first,
but all it takes is a dash of dye.
Glossier,
meaning double tongues thanks to a uniform written Chinese.
A book from Beijing can be read in Hong Kong,
but when locals Beijing travel to Hong Kong,
they find themselves surrounded by a completely different language.
Real future English be like this seesawing between a rigid,
cohesive language and a patchwork of local languages.
Even stranger are creoles languages that almost come to life out of the bones of
other languages.
Tope piecing in Papa New Guinea snags.
Most of its words from English,
but you couldn't tell by listening to it.
It's still full of foreign features.
Seriously,
they have different words for talking to one person,
two people,
three people or a bunch of people,
but it crystallized future English.
Is that a bit extreme now?
We haven't even reached the extreme.
What have been the wake of some catastrophe?
Only three speakers remain.
Think of those last speakers out there,
or think of the loneliest man on earth,
wandering the Amazon.
Are these the last breaths of once great languages?
Meanwhile,
whichever path you chose,
the future of ZoomCar seems pretty set.
It'll just keep following this equation.
Speed goes up,
more distance covered,
but things could go many ways for future English.
Come on.
Imagine the Scifi utopias or dystopias or flat out normal Topia is we might find
ourselves in.
So perhaps what we'll become a future English is not too different than asking
what will become of future us.